what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today we have some
really really cool details about what is
going to be happening in Deadpool 3. it
looks like we might know who one of the
main villains are and this ties directly
into the Illuminati from the 838
universe that we visited in Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness
there's also a rumor going around that
if true could potentially be insane just
ridiculously cool and it involves the
Fantastic Four specifically Jessica Alba
returning as the character the potential
for Deadpool 3 right now is just
absolutely insane and right now the
biggest report that we've heard about
Deadpool 3 you know besides Hugh Jackman
returning as Wolverine is that Deadpool
and Wolverine will visit a universe in
which the X-Men are in charge they rule
Earth above the humans the humans do
what they command them to do and this is
at the rule of Magneto but like I
mentioned it ties is into the 838
Illuminati that we met in Multiverse
Madness so we'll break down everything
you need to know about the recent report
in this video also if you're new be sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest videos and so you can
enter a giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox series X A PS5 so Marvel Legends
items and some DC items winner gets to
pick one item and we pick a winner at
the end of each month so we'll first
dive into a new villain report for
Deadpool 3 not going to be the main
villain but one of the main villains of
the film from what we've gathered from
multiple reports and rumors and actual
facts about the movie Deadpool and
Wolverine are going to be traveling
throughout the Multiverse if we go by
some previous reports they're doing this
to actually cooperate with the TVA if
they're Multiverse jumping it's very
clear that they are breaking some rules
and probably creating some Branch
timelines that the TVA and Mobius
definitely do not want to happen so it
could be a similar situation to what
Loki was instead of Simply pruning him
and erasing him from existence they
offer him a deal to help them that's
what we're looking at here Deadpool does
that gets captured by the TVA they offer
him a deal so it looks like he might be
going to multiple different universes
which is why there could be multiple
different villains now the villain that
is being reported today is that Emma
Corin the actress Emma Corin is going to
be portraying Cassandra Nova in Deadpool
3 and if you're not aware of who that is
it's actually Cassandra Nova Xavier the
sister of Charles Xavier Professor X now
in the comics she is actually evil she's
bad she's Charles Xavier's evil twin and
when they were in the womb together he
realized that she was evil due to his
psychic powers and he tried to kill her
they actually had a psychic battle in
the womb this report is coming from The
Insider can we get some toast who
reports in a tweet I can confirm that
Emma corin will be portraying Cassandra
Nova in Deadpool 3. in the comics
Cassandra Nova is Charles Xavier's evil
twin who is his equal and exact opposite
he tried to telepathically kill her in
the womb but she survives the attack and
spends her life rebuilding a body to
enact her revenge against him now what's
really interesting about this that we're
going to connect to the Illuminati for
Multiverse Madness is that Cassandra
Nova might not actually be evil in
Deadpool 3. keep in mind it's the
Multiverse we're gonna see variants who
might not be anything like what they're
like in the comics or maybe even just in
other universes in fact I hope and I
think a lot of fans are hoping that that
is what we see see different versions of
the same characters that we know perhaps
an evil Iron Man an evil Captain America
Hydra cap I hope we get stuff like this
and it looks like Cassandra Nova might
not be evil because somebody tweeted at
Insider Alex P from the cosmic circus
asking now there's information
everywhere that Cassandra Nova will
appear in Deadpool 3. do I understand
correctly that she wants to take revenge
on Wanda for Xavier's death in which
Alex P replied 838 Wants Revenge on six
one six the this kind of hints that
Cassandra Nova is actually going to be
sad mad upset whatever you want to call
it about the death of her brother
Charles Xavier and now she wants revenge
on Wanda from the 616 Universe our main
Universe for killing Charles Xavier and
the rest of the Illuminati and what's
interesting is how all of this ties
together because perhaps the universe
that we've been hearing about that
Deadpool and Wolverine visit that is
ruled by mutants could actually be the
838 universe that we visited in
Multiverse of Madness perhaps that is
why we have the Illuminati in that
Universe instead of a normal Avengers
team and that's why we had the X-Men in
that universe and Not Another Universe
and to make it even more interesting we
found out after the fact that they
almost included Magneto in that film
they actually wrote a scene that never
made it into the movie they did this for
a lot of characters that never actually
made the movie for example Daniel Craig
who of course played 007 was supposed to
play balder the brave this was confirmed
by Elizabeth Olsen herself and
apparently there were a lot of other
cameos that were in the script that
never made it but that could mean that
the 838 universe is that universe that
Deadpool and Wolverine will visit in
which the Illuminati and the mutants and
basically anybody with metahuman
superpowers or just any superhero they
rule the planet and they are now
connecting two different issues into one
which I'm actually really fond of 838 is
going to seek revenge on the 616
Universe I'm sure this will be addressed
not only in Deadpool 3 but outside of it
as well 616 Wanda are main Wanda dream
walked into the 838 universe and killed
the entire Illuminati team and here's
the really cool Fantastic Four rumor
that we heard about the Reed Richards
that was killed in that Universe John
Krasinski his wife because he did
confirm that he has a wife and kids
could be Jessica Alba's Sue storm AKA
The Invisible Woman now obviously this
would not be the exact same Sue Storm
from the original Fantastic Four movies
because she was obviously married to a
different Mr Fantastic she of course
would be a variant much like Charles
Xavier was a variant in Multiverse and
Madness it wasn't the same same one from
the original X-Men films but according
to a tweet from Knight Gambit who's a
film and TV reporter and editor-in-chief
for night Edge media he tweeted out
stating pretty sure she's 8382 with a
gif of Jessica Alba now we've heard that
some of the original Fantastic Four
members might return that didn't
necessarily mean that they would return
as the exact same characters they were
in the original movies meaning they
could be variants and I would love for
the original cast to return and be from
that other Universe however I would
settle for having Jessica Alba return in
any way shape or form as Sue storm and
Chris Evans returning as Johnny Storm
AKA The Human Torch because that is just
a Deadpool joke waiting to happen about
Chris Evans playing Captain America and
the Human Torch both Marvel characters
we know everybody wants that and Chris
Evans even said that he would like to
come back as the Human Torch when
talking about him returning as Captain
America he thought it would be too soon
if he even thought it would be a good
idea at all but what would like to
return as the Human Torch if this
universe is the 838 Universe perhaps
Jessica Alba could return as the wife of
now the late Mr Fantastic who was played
by John Krasinski and Chris Evans could
return as the brother of the now single
mother Sue storm and since the
Illuminati were made of the most
powerful people mutants and heroes in
that Universe yeah you can bet 838 is
probably pretty pissed at 616 for
letting their Wanda get out of control
and they did seem to have pretty good
knowledge on the Multiverse so I'm
betting that they have the capabilities
to jump multiverses which means they
could indeed one day come to Earth 616.
this could be one of the reasons that
incursions start to happen and the
Multiverse starts to essentially
collapse yes Kang and all of his
variants are going to be a big part of
it but people like Deadpool and maybe
characters from the 838 Universe are
going to also play a role on it plus
let's not forget about Loki and
everything that he caused to happen by
him and Sylvie killing he who remains
but that's all going to be addressed and
look you season two but it looks like
Professor Xavier's sister Cassandra Nova
is going to seek revenge for the death
of her brother and perhaps all the
heroes of the a38 universe are going to
seek revenge as well so we could have a
universal War here between the 838
universe and our main 616 Universe all
of this should be going down in Deadpool
3 and hopefully we'll tie into other
movies and maybe shows as well but let
us know what you think about all of this
news about Deadpool 3 in the comments
down below do you like where this is
going do you not leave all your thoughts
down below don't forget to like the
video and of course subscribe to the
channel so you can stay up to date on
all the latest MCU news you can follow
us on Instagram and Twitter as well and
as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf
baby